While creator Matt Groening is best known
for another little animated series he started
working on in the '80s, many fans would argue
that "Futurama" is his true magnum opus.
Here are some of the darkest "Futurama" fan
theories that you'll never be able to unlearn.
In "Parasites Lost," the fourth episode of
Season 3, Fry's legendary appetite gets the
better of him.
Despite Leela's objections, the dimwitted
delivery boy gets down with a questionable
sandwich from a space gas station, and predictably,
he finds his insides crawling with parasitic
worms.
Fortunately for Fry, these worms aren't concerned
with causing indigestion and diarrhea; instead,
they immediately get to work establishing
a society and improving their host body.
"Of all the parasites I've had over the years,
these worms are among the...oh, hell, they
are the best!"
The worms tone Fry's muscles, turning him
into a shredded god, and wire new synaptic
connections in his brain.
Their work bestows the lowly delivery boy
with super intelligence and the ability to
play the maddeningly difficult holophonor
— a musical instrument that projects holographic
images when expertly played.
The new Fry even catches Leela's eye, though
he ultimately becomes concerned that Leela
only loves him for his parasites.
In true "Futurama" fashion, Fry is cured of
his helpful parasites by the end of the episode,
but one fan theory suggests this wasn't the
end of the story — at least, not for Fry.
According to this dark theory, the parasites
left a hole in Fry's soul — the understanding
of his true potential.
Proponents of this theory argue that you can
see a marked change in Fry's behavior from
this point in the series on.
Forever haunted by the brief glimpse of personal
success that the parasites offered, Fry becomes
less irresponsible and more committed to self-improvement
to make himself once again worthy of Leela.
The last scene of the episode lends some credence
to this theory.
In that moment, Fry is seen sitting by himself
with a holophonor, attempting a rudimentary
melody that projects a sloppy portrait of
Leela.
It's a sad story, since Fry never again achieves
the heights of success afforded him by the
worms.
If you've only seen a few episodes of "Futurama"
here and there, you might have a hard time
imagining that Bender Bending Rodriguez was
ever anything other than the foul-mouthed,
beer-swilling, flatulent robot that we've
all come to know and love.
But what if that roguish personality on display
for 139 of the show's 140 episodes was nothing
more than a run time error?
According to one disturbing theory, Bender
just wasn't the same robot before his happenstance
meeting outside the suicide booth with Philip
J. Fry in the show's very first episode.
When the two future roommates first met in
the pilot, they were both on the verge of
dying — Bender by intention, and Fry by
mistake.
We learn in the course of their meet-cute
that Bender used to help make suicide booths
by bending the metal girders used in their
construction.
This sad, blue collar bending robot willing
to take his own life out of shame for the
moral repugnance of his profession is a bit
of a departure from the Bender who signs up
to crew Professor Farnsworth's delivery ship.
So, what changed?
According to one fan theory, the big shift
happened just moments later, when Bender is
electrocuted in The Head Museum's Hall of
Criminals.
After that shock, Bender seems much more willing
to bend the rules, pun intended, and go along
with Fry's escape plan while they run from
the cops.
The theory suggests that this one shock was
enough to reboot Bender's entire personality.
We actually see a version of this play out
in a later episode, when Bender is rebooted
as a result of trauma from a killer whale
attack.
That reboot makes Bender act like a penguin,
suggesting that his surroundings at the time
of reboot actually do impact his personality
algorithm.
Zapp Brannigan is one of the most memorable
secondary characters on "Futurama."
When the bumbling starship captain was first
introduced, he was little more than a one-dimensional,
self-aggrandizing buffoon — a satire of
characters like William Shatner's James Kirk,
original captain of the Starship Enterprise.
That all changes on subsequent episodes, however,
as the character accrues significant depth
across several intersecting missions with
the Planet Express crew.
He gains so much depth, in fact, that some
fans have theorized that some of his behavior
may be explained by PTSD.
This dark theory weaves together several disparate
pieces of Brannigan's slowly unfolding backstory
into a tapestry of woe.
The canonical "Futurama" comics help explain
some things, by establishing that Brannigan
was the greatest military recruit the Democratic
Order of Planets had ever seen.
He was so gifted, in fact, that scientists
hoped to make him into an army by cloning
him.
The experiment was botched, leaving Brannigan
as a sex-crazed, junk food-craving, diminished
version of his former self.
His early successes help explain why he was
able to rise through the ranks despite the
experiment gone wrong, but then things seem
to take a darker turn.
According to Zapp himself, his crowning military
achievement came when he vanquished the Killbots
by making the decision to send every single
one of his soldiers into battle simultaneously,
thus overwhelming the Killbots' programming.
Such a gutsy surge tactic likely came with
substantial human casualties, a cost that
this theory suggests has haunted Zapp ever
since.
Tortured by the post-traumatic stress of losing
so many men, Brannigan's already self-destructive
tendencies only got worse.
So, we got a formerly great soldier who became
a formerly great captain, a shell of his former
self more concerned with women and food than
he is with service.
It's hard to laugh at a serious psychological
disorder like PTSD, so we really hope this
theory isn't true, but we'd be lying if we
said it doesn't make a lot of sense.
Of all the Futurama fan theories out there
in the multiverse, this one is definitely
the darkest.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.